I just don't as a mother fucker and go on and stayed.
So Friday I went to the store and I swear to God guys,
I didn't eat nothing all day.
I smoked some pot I worked at before I left the house.
It was a little Brownie.
Let's 70 milligram brownies.
I have like maybe 13 carbs left for the day.
I was fucking starving.
This little is right there.
It was a half a pack of an anarchy edible.
They give you two brownies.
Each brownie.
It's 70 milligrams.
That's so crazy and scary.
I rub my balls are 70 milligrams.
You understand me?
70 milligrams uncle Joey is,
it's like an Aperitif.
It's not even a fucking explaining to the rest of the world.
70 milligrams.
We'll put you into a fucking hole.
You know,
I gave him a 500 last night.
He shoots,
we split,
we
split
milligram edible and song down at the hall.
Oh my God.
Listen to me.
We split it at three o'clock in the afternoon.
Oh my God.
What are you trying to prove?
I seven o'clock.
I was so fucked by eight o'clock and you know,
usually when you eat your tamed animal,
Fuck No,
this turned on me.
This animal turn red dog.
Like I shot bitch beat me at the submissions.
At one point I had the cheese doodles that belongs to the baby pirate's booty.
They were on the floor.
They were just coming out of my face.
I was just stuff.
I was just stuffing pirate's booty in my face and a pair I couldn't stop.
I kept eating peaches and pirate's booty,
pirate's booty,
cantaloupe and pirate's booty.
I must state the whole baby.
My wife was like,
oh.
Cause I had my back turned to them so they couldn't see me.
My wife's like,
what the fuck are you doing it?
I go,
listen,
I gotta go to this bed.
She goes,
go to bed already.
I went to [inaudible] 45 I slept till four I got up,
I didn't know where I was.
30 minutes like Mad Max.
I just laid bill c four in the morning.
You didn't know where you were.
So low.
I put 30 I woke up when a car,
the energy,
energy,
I wanted to shower.
I washed the car breakfast.
Oh my God.
I was fucked up and I kept calling lead and say elite.
If the cops,
coy don't answer the phone,
and he goes,
well,
I haven't comps on the court.
And I got on that,
but they'll answer.